This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. If you're a parent, you've probably told your kids a thousand times, your room is a mess, clean it up. Managers tell their employees to get organized. Here in the United States, we elect presidents to go clean up Washington. In the next half of our show today, we explore a very different idea. What happens if we treat chaos as our friend instead of our enemy? Tim Hartford believes we should do just that. He's the author of Messy, the power of disorder
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。如果你是父母，你可能已经对孩子们说过一千遍了：你的房间太乱了，快去收拾干净。经理们告诉员工要有条理。在美国，我们选举总统去华盛顿进行整顿。在今天节目的后半部分，我们将探讨一个非常不同的想法。如果我们把混乱当作朋友而不是敌人会怎么样？蒂姆·哈特福德认为我们应该这样做。他是《混乱：无序的力量》一书的作者
to transform our lives. He joined us recently for a live taping. We were just blocks from the White House at NPR's Weekend in Washington. It's an annual event that brings together public radio fans and supporters. Tim Hartford, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, Shankar. I want to begin by playing you a piece of music come about? What's the story? It's beautiful, isn't it? Two of my children were born to that. It was played by Keith Jarrett, great jazz pianist, in 1975 in Cologne. And if you had been there two or three hours before the concert,
来改变我们的生活。他最近参加了我们的现场录音。我们在距离白宫仅几个街区的NPR华盛顿周末活动上录制。这是一个每年汇聚公共广播迷和支持者的盛会。蒂姆·哈特福德，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢你，尚卡尔。我想先给你播放一段音乐，它是怎么来的？背后的故事是什么？这很美，不是吗？我的两个孩子伴随着这段音乐出生。这是基思·贾雷特于1975年在科隆演奏的，他是一位伟大的爵士钢琴家。如果你在音乐会开始前两三个小时去到现场，
you would not have expected things to go well. Mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio' cylwodio'r cylwodio'r cylwodio yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch the concert because they want a documentary evidence of what a musical catastrophe sounds like, so they could play it to future promoters to tell them to do a good job and get a proper piano. But in fact, it's a masterpiece. It's Keith Jarrett's most popular work. In fact, it's the best selling jazz album in history, solo jazz album in history, and the best-selling piano album in history is the Column Concert. And the surprising thing is that all the adjustments that Jarrett had to make to cope with this bad piano made the music better. So we avoided the harsh upper registers, he stuck to the middle of the keyboard, that makes it sound very soothing. But he also had to compensate for the fact that piano was so quiet, so he had these rolling repetitive riffs in the bass to try to get some resonance. And he also had to compensate for the fact that piano was so quiet so he had these rolling repetitive riffs in the bass
你绝对不会预料到事情会进展顺利。コンサートの前に、彼らは音楽的な大惨事がどのように聞こえるかのドキュメンタリー証拠を欲しがっていたため、将来のプロモーターに良い仕事をして適切なピアノを手に入れるように伝えることができました。しかし実際、それは傑作です。それはキース・ジャレットの最も人気のある作品です。実際、それは歴史上最も売れているジャレットのジャレットの、歴史上最も売れているソロジャレットアルバムであり、歴史上最も売れているピアノアルバムはコローンコンサートです。そして驚くべきことは、ジャレットがこの悪いピアノに対処するために行わなければならなかったすべての調整が音楽を良くしたということです。したがって、厳しい高音域を避け、キーボードの中央に固執しました。それはそれを非常に心地よく聞こえさせます。しかし、彼はまた、ピアノが非常に静かであったという事実を補償しなければならなかったので、彼は共鳴を得るために低音でこれらのローリングリピーティブリーフを持っていました、そして彼はまたピアノが非常に静かであったという事実を補償しなければならなかったので彼は低音でこれらのローリングリピーティブリーフを持っていました
to try to get some resonance and he also just stood up and pounded down on the keys so you can hear him moaning in frustration during the concert he's hating it but it is amazing And that combination of the peacefulness and the dynamism makes this electrifying piece of music. So he did not expect that a bad piano would produce a great concert, but in fact it did. And the argument in my book is very often we're faced with the unplayable piano
为了尽量产生一些共鸣，他也只是站起来重重地砸在琴键上，所以你能在音乐会期间听到他沮丧地呻吟，他讨厌这样，但这太惊人了。这种平静感与动感结合在一起，造就了一首激动人心的音乐。因此，他绝没有料到一把坏钢琴会带来一场伟大的音乐会，但事实确实如此。我书中的观点是，我们经常会遇到无法弹奏的钢琴
and actually we produce something great out of it. You have a number of examples besides Keet Gerrit about how disruptions and inconveniences and surprises can sometimes have paradoxically good effects on us, even though we all try to avoid those disruptions. You talk about commuters for example, who suddenly have to find a new way to work, or scientists who are working on so many projects that they're discombobulated, because
并且实际上从它那里创作出了伟大的作品。除了基思·贾雷特之外，你还有许多例子说明了干扰、不便和惊喜有时如何对我们产生矛盾的好影响，尽管我们都极力避免这些干扰。例如，你谈到了那些突然不得不寻找新上班路线的通勤者，或者是那些因有太多项目而焦头烂额的科学家，因为
they don't know what they're working on. In many of these cases, you find that disorder and confusion could actually be helpful. Yeah, so in the case of commuters, there was a transport strike in London a couple of years ago. Shutdown,r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a' a'r trweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000%
他们不知道自己在忙些什么。在许多情况下，你会发现无序和混乱实际上是有帮助的。是的，对于通勤者来说，几年前伦敦发生过一次交通罢工。完全关闭，交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的交通罢工的
yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000%ch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i' One of the things I want to do in this conversation is try and tease apart when messiness can be our friend and when it can be our enemy. There's a reason many of us try and avoid messiness. It's because messiness causes delays. It causes disruptions. You're ending up being late for some things.
1000% 1000% 1000% 1000% 1000% 1000%我要在这场对话中做的事情之一，就是试图剖析混乱何时可以成为我们的朋友，何时又会成为我们的敌人。我们许多人试图避免混乱是有原因的。那是因为混乱会导致延误。它会导致中断。你最终做某些事情会迟到。
And I'm wondering as I read some of the examples in your book, whether it was the case that messiness helps people who actually have a base of preparation. So in other words, Keith Jarrett, he's a professional musician, he's very gifted, he's practiced and he's learned the rules of how to play a proper piano for years and years and years. You placed me before that piano, and what you're going to hear is not genius, what you're going to hear is just a mess. And the reason Keith Jarrett could adapt was because he had the base of knowing the rules to now say I can throw out the rule book and create something brilliant.
我想知道，当我阅读你书中的一些例子时，混乱是否在实际上拥有准备基础的人身上发挥作用？换句话说，基思·贾雷特是一名专业音乐家，他非常有天赋，经过多年年复一年的练习，学会了如何弹奏一架正规钢琴的规则。你把我放在那架钢琴前，你听到的将不是天才，你听到的只是一团糟。而基思·贾雷特之所以能够适应，是因为他有着了解规则的基础，从而现在能够说：我可以抛开规则手册，创造出一些绝妙的东西。
Yeah, I think that's absolutely right, Shankar. Is it okay, can I open a big bag of complexity science on you? Absolutely. Okay, so basically, if you are trying to solve a very complex problem, we have various algorithms that try to solve this. And we'll come to the question of skill in a second. a'r ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn yydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gyd and you should probably avoid most of that part. And that thing with the pedals, don't do that either. But then he sits down at the piano and then his skill kicks in and he's looking for the incremental improvements.
是的，我认为完全正确，尚卡尔。可以吗，我可以向你抛出一个复杂的科学大礼包吗？当然可以。好的，基本上，如果你试图解决一个非常复杂的问题，我们有各种算法试图解决这个问题。我们一会儿就会讨论技能的问题。和那些痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦的工作，痛苦.并且你可能应该避开大部分那部分。至于那个带踏板的东东，也别那么做。但随后他坐到钢琴前，他的技能便开始发挥作用，他在寻找渐进式的改进。
He's looking for a path to find great music. And he finds it. So yes, you need skill, but the random shocks help. So for all the children who are listening to this podcast, I want to make clear that you're not saying that every time your parent tells you to clean up the room, you should just say, Tim Hartford says, I shouldn't.
他在寻找寻找伟大音乐的途径。而且他找到了。所以，是的，你需要技能，但随机的冲击是有帮助的。因此，对于所有正在收听这个播客的孩子们，我想明确一点：你并不是在说，每当你的父母叫你收拾房间时，你都应该说：蒂姆·哈特福德说过，我不应该这么做。
Well, I have to say, since writing the book, I have stopped asking my children to clear up their room. And the reason is, the reason is, I read an amazing study that had been conducted by two British psychologist, Alex Haslam and Craig Knight. Mae'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaith yn ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymw peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymw yw'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gwe Nobody should make me a boss, by the way. If I'm ever a boss, I will never impose a clean desk policy. And number two, me and my wife, we kind of are the boss in our house, and I no longer ask my children to tidy their rooms. And you know what? We don't argue about it as much. And the rooms are kind of as messy as they ever were.
好吧，我必须说，自从写了这本书以来，我再也不要求我的孩子们收拾他们的房间了。原因在于，原因在于，我读到了一项由两位英国心理学家亚历克斯·哈斯勒姆和克雷格·奈特进行的出色研究。这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，这项工作的成果，顺便说一句，没人能让我当老板。如果我当了老板，我绝不会强推整洁桌面的政策。第二，我和我妻子算是我家的“老板”，我不再要求我的孩子们整理他们的房间了。你知道吗？我们为此争吵得少多了。而且房间依然和以前一样乱。
It hasn't made any difference to the physical state of the rooms. It's just a little bit more peace. All right, so that's a perfect segue to what I want to talk about next, because I actually want to talk about office space and how we organize office spaces. And in fact, I have a clip from the cult classic movie, Office Space, which I'm going to play for you. Hi, Milton. What's happening? I'm sorry.
房间的物理状态没有任何改变。只是多了一点平静。好的，这完美地衔接了我接下来想谈的话题，因为我实际上想谈谈办公空间以及我们如何组织办公空间。事实上，我有一个来自经典邪典电影《办公空间》的片段，我要放给你听。嗨，米尔顿。怎么了？我很抱歉。
I'm going to have to ask you to go ahead and move your desk again So if you could go ahead and get it as far back against that wall as possible that would be great No, no, because I was that way. We'll have some room for some of these Boxes and things we need to put in here There it is what here. Let me just go ahead and get that front. Great. So, if you could just get to that as soon as possible, that would be terrific. Okay. Thanks a bunch, Melden.
我得请你把你的办公桌再挪一下。所以如果你能尽量把它靠紧那堵墙，那就太好了。不，不，因为我刚才就是那样。这样我们就有空间放一些我们需要放进这里的箱子和其他东西了。就是这样。来吧，我把前面弄一下。太好了。所以，如果你能尽快把它弄好，那就太棒了。好的。非常感谢，米尔顿。
Bye. Okay. I can sit and building on fire. So I take a tim that you're not a fan of fascist office managers, but you do also tell the story in the book about Steve Jobs at Pixar and some of the ideas he had about how to organize office space to make people more collaborative and some of the ways that might have backed fire. Yeah, the Pixar story I think is fascinating. So Steve Jobs, majority shareholder at Pixar, had a big hand in designing the Pixar building.
再见。好吧，我可以坐在着火的大楼里。所以我猜蒂姆你不是法西斯办公经理的粉丝，但你在书中也讲述了史蒂夫·乔布斯在皮克斯的故事，以及他关于如何组织办公空间以使人们更多地进行合作的一些想法，以及其中一些可能会适得其反的方式。是的，皮克斯的故事我认为非常吸引人。所以史蒂夫·乔布斯作为皮克斯的大股东，在设计皮克斯大楼时发挥了很大作用。
And one of his big ideas is we are going to make all the bathrooms in this building in the middle of the building. We're just going to have two big restrooms, a pair of restrooms in the heart of the building. And what that will do is everyone will come together, brought together by a shared yn ymwch i'n gweithio, ac mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio. Ym'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
他的一个宏大想法是，我们要把这栋楼里所有的洗手间都设在楼的正中央。我们只在大楼的心脏地带设置两个大的洗手间，一对洗手间。而这样做的效果是，每个人都会聚到一起，由一个共同的东西拉近距离。在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里工作，在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 work,在这里 not found. Setting default value: 0
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio, a'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio' I know this sounds like a great idea on paper, Mr. Jobs, but I need to go to the restroom three times an hour. And you've just made the restroom 10 minutes away from my desk and do the maths. And it's not going to work. And Steve Jobs did an amazing thing. He backed down. He said, OK, I'm wrong.
not found. Setting default value: 0
I will find another way to create Serendipitous Interactions. And you can have your restrooms all over the Pixar offices, which is where they are. Mae'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwybod yw'r gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybodbod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn g of control over. It looks like a total mess. In other words, it looks like your children's rooms. Yeah, maybe slightly more creative than my children's rooms, but my children aspire towards the whole Disney Castle thing. Tim Hartford comes from Britain. We're having this chat in the United States. In both countries, there have been enormous political upheavals recently.
When we come back, I'm going to ask Tim about messiness in public life and in democracy. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. With Brexit and the election of Donald Trump term, we've had populous revolutions on both sides of the Atlantic that reject the advice of scientists and economists, experts in general. Democracy, of course, is famously messy. Could you remind people why it's such a good thing? Yes. I think in both cases, I try to remind myself
not found. Setting default value: 0
of Keith Jarrett's unplayable piano, actually. To me, the Brexit vote felt like an unplayable piano. The expert consensus in the UK was that this was not a very good idea. i'n unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn y frustrated, but we should then say, OK, how is this going to make me stronger? How is this going to make my society stronger? What are the solutions that are going to come out of disappointment? Donald Trump ran a campaign that many people thought was extremely disordered. He didn't listen to the experts.
He went off script all the time. He said things that people said would be sure to make him lose. Now your book came out only a few weeks ago, but clearly he must have read an early draft. I, tonight leaking the book to Donald Trump. However, you're absolutely right, there is a section in the book about Donald Trump's campaigning style that was written before he won the election and it was published before he won the election. yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaith understand what's going on, but at least Bonson Noble are more confused than we are. And as long as Bonson Noble are more confused than we are, we're doing okay. He was very, very clear about this and it has proved very effective.
not found. Setting default value: 0
I want to talk about another example of messiness in public life and I want you to watch this video which describes a very famous speech and I want to ask the question right after it. We can never be satisfied as long as our children are stripped of their selfhood and robbed of their dignity by sign stating for white's own name. We cannot be satisfied as long as a Negro in Mississippi cannot go and a Negro in New York believes he has nothing for which to go. So as you can see from that speech, Tim, Martin Luther King is reading from a script. And he has some nice line there, but it's a right early line. But at a certain point in this speech, he decides to leave the
script behind and turn his eyes to the audience, and here's what we see after that. I still have a dream. It is a dream deeply rooted in the American dream. I have a dream. But one day, this nation will rise up and live out the true meaning of its creed. We hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created. Talk about this for a second, because you talk about this speech in the book, and you
not found. Setting default value: 0
talk about this moment when King left his notes behind and essentially stepped off the ledge of what he knew and what he was certain about and just rode the wave of what the crowd was telling him and what he was feeling. He had prepared that speech meticulously the night before, but it stayed up very late. He was operating on a number of constraints. It was quite a tight time schedule. The eyes of the world were on him, he knew that. Yn gyd ymdwyr yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn fio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweith looked and he realized it's not working. It's now let us go back to our communities as members for the Society for Creative Disatisfaction. He doesn't say it. He says instead, go back to Alabama. Go back to Alabama, go back to South Carolina, go back to Georgia, go back to Louisiana,
谈谈马丁·路德·金放下讲稿的那一刻，他实际上跨出了自己所知和确信的边界，顺应着人群传达的信息和内心的感受。他前一天晚上精心准备了那篇演讲，但熬夜很晚。他受到许多限制，时间非常紧迫。全世界的目光都聚焦在他身上，他深知这一点。当他环顾四周，意识到行不通时，他没有说“让我们作为‘创造性不满协会’的成员回到我们的社区”。他没有这么说。相反，他说，回到阿拉巴马。回到阿拉巴马，回到南卡罗来纳，回到佐治亚，回到路易斯安那，
go back to the slums and get holes in our northern cities. And there's another pause, and the people behind him on the stage know he's not on the script anymore. And Mahalia Jackson, great gospel singer, yells out to him because she's heard him talking in church about this dream. She yells out, tell him about the dream Martin. And then he starts to improvise. And that is when he touches the crowd. I want to wrap by asking you a few personal questions. I understand that after writing this book,
回到我们北方城市的贫民窟和贫民区。又是一次停顿，舞台上他身后的人知道他已经脱稿了。玛哈莉亚·杰克逊，伟大的福音歌手，大声对喊他，因为她听过他在教堂里谈论过这个梦想。她大喊：马丁，告诉他那个梦想。然后他开始即兴发挥。就在那时，他触动了人群。我想以几个私人问题作为结束。我理解，在写完这本书之后，
every time you find yourself in a mess and you turn to your wife for comfort, she now reminds you that being in a mess is a good thing. Yeah. Actually, just two days ago, Shankar, I was trying to check into a hotel, a Dublin airport, midnight, knowing that I was going to have to get up very early in the morning and fly and then come over to Washington to speak to you. Just desperate to get that little bit of sleep that I would be able to get.
每当你陷入困境并向妻子寻求安慰时，她现在都会提醒你，陷入困境是一件好事。是的。事实上，就在两天前，香卡，我正试图在都柏林机场的一家酒店办理入住，当时是半夜，我知道自己得起得很早乘飞机，然后来华盛顿和你对话。我当时极度渴望能获得哪怕一点点睡眠。
When I showed up at the airport hotel, they didn't have my reservation. And they were full. a'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
当我出现在机场酒店时，他们没有我的预订，而且客满了。
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
客满了。
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gfeelu'r yw'r pethu'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ywy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r f and that's a problem for us. Tim Hartford, thank you for joining me today. Thank you, Shaka. Today's show was produced by Chris Benderef, Maggie Pennman, Jenny Schmidt, Renee Clark and Raina Cohen. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our intern is Chloe Connelly. For more Hidden Brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter and subscribe to our weekly podcast. Each week on Hidden Brain, we name an unsung hero, someone who works behind the scenes,
这给我们带来了麻烦。蒂姆·哈特福德，谢谢你今天加入我。谢谢你，香卡。今天的节目由克里斯·本德雷夫、玛吉·彭曼、珍妮·施密特、蕾妮·克拉克和雷娜·科恩制作。我们的主管制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。我们的实习生是克洛伊·康纳利。要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在脸书和推特上找到我们，并订阅我们的每周播客。每周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们都会表彰一位无名英雄，一个在幕后默默工作、
but doesn't always get the recognition they deserve. Our unsung hero this week is Karleen Watson. Karleen is the executive producer of all things considered, and she's been a wonderful resource as hidden brain has grown and taken on different forms. Her sharp editorial judgment and kind support are equally invaluable. Thanks Karleen. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. Trunkervet Anthem and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
却不一定总能得到应有认可的人。我们本周的无名英雄是卡琳·沃森。卡琳是《All Things Considered》的执行制作人，随着《隐藏的大脑》不断成长并呈现出不同的形式，她一直是极好的资源。她敏锐的编辑判断力和亲切的支持同样弥足珍贵。谢谢你，卡琳。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。